[Applause]
all
country um
so this is awesome this like a massive
turn out thank
you
um so we're going to focus on
uh aess how get that nice with
awareness of how you can interact with
your boy playes this stuff also does
really fly nicely to just about any
spinning profit we're going to be toy
focused um
and I haven't done much sleep over the
last4 hours so I'm going to need crowd
participation um both in helping me
illustrate various CL things like that
and in helping me remember the points of
the stuff that we explore through today
there's some like new twists on things
that I've been playing with that I'm
going to be with you guys get like the
fresh new alien Twist on on this
material um and at the
end uh we're going to do a little video
class Note review because it's really
awesome when you learn all this stuff
for a couple hours and it's really
exciting and then a week later you're
like
wait so we can we can do a little review
get it on video and if you guys all work
personally and together to help remember
like any aha moments that you have or
like points about what we're learning
that like really like stuck out for you
when I'm recording you can remind me to
make sure I mentioned that specific
thing so it's on the video for you on
YouTube later on so you can go back few
week and remember
what all
right that's said uh you guys are all
probably way more warmed up than I am
down and do a quick warm
up
right be
[Laughter]
[Music]
J okay
so
good
um so let's let's go ahead and pick up
our boy basic basic sweeping
turn we've all probably done it before
it for uh together Time same
direction as your PO but I want I want
you to bring some awareness to when you
start the turn when you're Midway
through the turn and when you really
sort of finish
it so in line with what we were doing
with our hands your PO going to be
swinging down as they sweep past the
Horizon that's really when you have to
commit to starting your
turn your PO will be sweeping past the
ground halfway through and
finishing as the PO come up to the
Horizon as well you've all done this
before I just want you to try to really
pay attention to those
moments yeah we might have to this this
footwork if you want to spice it up even
more instead of just simply opening
the
like
this right we
position but
totally into
play and keep in mind like I'm not
thinking about this stuff when I'm
dancing and it took a while before I
broke it down this
far uh but it's it's nice to take second
to really focus on some of these details
and get to know how the body is moving
ingrain it in your practice enough so
that you can sort of forget it and let
it be there informing what you're doing
when you're actually playing with your
prods that's that's the end goal not to
be
going yeah that's what we
want it's sort of I mean it's it's like
learning musical scales you don't want
to try to be improvising in a band and
like really analytically trying to think
about like what you're doing your scales
you want to have played with them enough
where you totally forget it you just
feel out of your
fingers yeah yeah
exactly
okay everybody feel done it
yeah well this that's exactly it this
whole first part of this stuff it's like
it's an awful lot of what we've all done
before without consciously looking at
what's going on can you can you describe
that one more time real quick yes so
lousy
footwork split split time
opposites has the characteristic that
the poy meet each other on the left and
right side or on the horizon it's as
though there's a horizontal mirror
there even even when I'm
here I'm I'm sort of looking for I'm
trying to feel my rhythm like notice the
focus point of when the
boy meet the Horizon like Pac-Man
chomping closing his mouth or like a
scissoring action so that's my rhythm
right there and that's what initiates
when I turn here and close here so
that's like the motion
changes yeah so it
gives exactly
exactly it's really simple it boils down
to either you're going to transition
when your arms look like this together
on the horizon or separate on the
horizon the be man style like that's it
there's more to it than that this is
like such touch the foundation like any
sort of transitional stuff
here or
here it's all here watching your
[Laughter]
footwork
so uh yeah let's take let's let's
uh just give it a little more time on
the for those who want to play with the
split time thing let me let's actually
you know what no I think let's have
everybody just try the split time
opposites out with just your hands you
can either put your poy down or wrap
them up so you have little targets
little around so right we're starting
out toes pointing down the hallway hands
are on the horizon um just just let's
let's Okay we we'll all be uniform put
your right Point your right hand up your
left hand down that's the direction
they're going to go so from here you're
going to step and open up let them get
to that place high and low so that you
want to have the right hand went all the
way up the left went all the way down
and then you continue on bring to the
Horizon again now down the left up same
deal step open up left's all the way up
right all the way down they continue on
closing finishing the turn at the
Horizon is like in line on this plane
exactly yeah if you are a quarter turn
if your body's turned a quarter turn and
you're like in in wheel plane doing
something then facing this way of course
I'm going to get like that because this
is actually meant to be on that plane
and this is meant to be on thate
but from the side it looks
okay
yeah body motion we're going to stand
facing each other and imagine our wall
playe gear it's a glass one we can like
touch hands through we like
mes
okay the the idea though is that yeah
we're we're essentially by touching each
other's hands we're sort of insinuating
this plan here physically
and we're going to start out by placing
the hands over here and allowing a
little bit of torso turn like let your
belly button in your your serum to the
point over there where your hands are on
the horizon fingers Point into the
Horizon and let's uh let's move the
outer hands up and the lower hands down
the lower hands will roll back to back
and we're going to turn and face each
other and take a moment with your
partner sort of check your posture and
check that you're actually align on the
center line of the body then continue on
by turning your torso getting the hands
Pac-Man Chomps on the horizon continuing
on and notice how you can like you can
really as as this starts getting
comfortable and smooth it can really
become a lot about like the Torso
turning like turning your torso together
in a
mirror
and we're just going to Pivot our foot
and step around here to make another
half turn to pce the other
wall wall
plane if you have like you know a wall
you can stand in front of a home or like
here I sort of picked this little
l in the
pav or you have a brave friend you have
stand I don't know how Brave
that so we're going to go through four
quarter turns so I haven't super
emphasized it in this one but I did sort
of touch on the quarter turn thing
there's really like four cardinal
directions that you're sort of phasing
through as you turn your body W and same
thing with spinning like there's all
these fours without getting too deep
into it has to do with angular momentum
and right angles and sort of how the
universe managed to stack itself up that
way it works great but suffice to say
that we're sort of going through these
four cardinal orientations and with all
the stuff we're playing with we're we're
wanting to feel comfortable in each of
those positions like pausing there and
spinning there and also comfortable just
flowing through them in
um so what we're going to do now is
we're going to start out facing a
wall coid dangling on that wall and
we're going
to make a quarter turn so that we're our
shoulders to the wall which means one PO
is easily hanging down the other PO is
dangling over that shoulder because
these po are always going to stay on
this wall no matter how we turn our
body and we're going to keep turning our
back to the wall
make a final quarter turn and we're back
where we
started and our body made a full circle
and the toy had made a full circle but
they never left this
plane me show
you
with this I should essentially be able
to like put my point touching this wall
and as I
turn I should never have to lose contact
with that plane with that
wall the tricky
part is this whole when it theing over
your
should think about this and teach it
is that your Foy and the arm holding
it through that Archway so that you can
actually get the koi behind your head
and continuing
on so there's this there's a really
nice so from so check this out like here
yeah there exactly then the the the the
tricky part is from the back this hand
has to like you
thre
yes this is this is definitely this is
shoulder intensive for
sure one one drop down in like a of
simple
long one that's Sing Down the uh the one
that comes past the shoulder is is one
of these guys sort
of behind your
head so to to take this from exercise to
something that sort of like a nice move
potentially you're trying to get a
timing
[Applause]
where
just so we're sort of starting with the
building blocks we want to work with
let's play with the arm wrapping um more
or less it's like isolating around your
arm even if it's only a little isolation
instead of like you really
full there and there are two varieties
that's sort of important to know look
for and get comfortable with both of
these feelings um I think maybe the
easier one is to start out hanging
hanging the POI at your wrist and you're
going to be dragging the POI head around
after your
hand all right is that is that I you
know maybe is that what the glow ringers
call it really try to try to keep
contact though like literally even if
you have to do it really slow at first
like drag it around So eventually you
won't have to make contact but yeah yeah
yeah see that that whole thing where
like your hand is definitively leading
and the poy head is isolating and
following your hand you flick the poy
head around your arm so that the poy
head is leading and your hand is
chasing so awesome right and a lot of
people when you're sort of like finding
your way through barrels and things like
don't notice that there are those two
distinctly different ways that like one
PO is is chasing and one is leading
around the arm both of those things are
going on and that's just with like your
standard sort of barrel rolles like
these components show up in all sorts of
other more exotic moves with ins swings
and Butterfly barrel rolls and weird
stuff like that
so it's I think it's it's worthwhile for
us to start out here for a second and
like isolate mentally isolate that there
are these two things that you want to
get comfortable with cuz both of them
are feelings that you probably haven't
experienced before unless you've really
grilled this stuff can you give a brief
example of the poy head leading but with
both fans I will do it in slow motion
slow
mo I've heard about teaching Koy like
this yeah yeah so notice blue end red
end I'll hold on to the blue end okay so
if the head is leading you're you got to
sort of flick it through your arm but
then notice how as I am like more or
less isolating the head is
always leading around my arm and my hand
is chasing after it okay so that this is
very much feels like an isolation around
your arm you have to have enough arm
movement with the other arm or else
it'll just get stalled out on your arm
in order to repeat that with po
and it looks like
this right so you see the like the
isolation with a little
like the red there to sort of get it
over the top that that's really
important to be able to get it around
your arm yeah it's like a small delay
almost
yeah sounds like the other one and so
that's sort of like starting with the
head is coming on the out side of your
arm yeah far away from my body the other
one I'm starting with the forehead sort
of dangling inside my arm close to my
body and I'm taking the handle and
dragging
it around so now my hand and the handle
keeps leading this is the first one we
actually did yeah my handle keeps
leading pulling the Pye head around in
an isolation with it entering snakes
from like the back position for
instance notice how my elbows and hands
are bringing the handles
first handles went first dragging the PO
head around from front to back I flick
the PO head back so that the P head go
first and the handles follow it up so if
you get used to this feeling in general
and start sort of noticing it in the
things you're trying to do of well I'm
sort of doing an isolation is the
forehead leading or is my hand leading
uh that'll really start to bring
Consciousness and Clarity in how the
heck you got to move your body to make
it do that thing you're trying to do
with isolations so
yeah um if you're moving that sort of
isolation around your handle and the
head are leap frogging right like you're
taking turns sort of the head's coming
in and then it's dipping while the
handle overtakes it like that sort of
thing so that's what's happening with a
snake like in instead of just instead of
just dragging this around making an
ellipse you're you're coming in with
like a momentary isolation or like a
loop or a stall they're all really sort
of the same thing just slightly
different flavors different exaggerated
motions so here
comes the PO head came in and now the
handle is going to sort of leak frog
around your shoulder which drags this
out it keeps going right so the momentum
makes it more like a static prop than
anything yeah
okay I like it any of these names so
much but a not Coleman 3 or a buz saw
weave or
a yeah um this is I think what you you
were talking about starting with the
like starting here right yeah and then
bring the one up under so yeah like
check this out we could even start just
hanging it there pretending we're
spinning
forward so you're going to take
whichever hand's on the bottom and use
this hand to drag it up through the
center of your arms like this this
basket that your arms
make and out and around putting it
back same side right so it never comes
it doesn't get all the way back to its
own side it comes through and to the
Cross side through and to the Cross side
when a barrel turn to be a little too uh
slow reacting cuz I noticed you have to
like put it far out afterward like I EX
hydrating no actually like once once you
get this going this is what it will look
like oh
okay key key does a lot of nice nice
lady things with this I
notic that's intrinsically link with
flipping your wrist flipping sides so
here my wrist is going uh
clockwise over here it's having to
rotate counterclockwise that feeling of
sort of changing sides happened
um
but uh what if you just like go from
armpit to over the arm like make a
figure eight like this for a second get
used to how that
feels arm pit other arm armpit other arm
so you you never flip your wrist right
in fact if you were to turn this way
that's like it's like for at the needle
yeah the only the only other time with
like sort of beginner basic Co mov that
people experience not flipping their
wrist and doing figure eight that way is
pushing and pulling through the needle
which if you look at it from the side is
in fact still making figure eight shapes
but you're just not flipping your wrists
so a lot of these inversion things
um involve this like moving the PO
around your other arm and doing all this
stuff with way
less down through the
hole so from the top is going scarier
like it's it's coming at your face yeah
exactly it's okay I'm used to a staff so
this is also another place where you
really want to see to see if you can
like get the hand like drag the handle
under the more you do that the more you
isolate the smaller the circle gets the
farther away from your face it is nice
or it looks like a little extra
cool are you
um you're just dragging the handle
around the back right you're not doing
the poy head going over isolation exctly
this is all handle dragging this has not
involved the head bleeding yet okay is
that what inion
means question solution there okay
answer that question
later these invol inversions what we're
doing right now based on the most verb
technical definition that a lot of
people go by now isn't an
inversion inversion like involves in
swing which is what we're doing which is
when when you end up creating this Frame
here this basket with your arms and
Swinging The Boy in between
[Music]
oh got that right getting it now by
creating an inswing using an inswing
it's this very
smooth almost mind gamey sort of like
way to switch up what you're doing and
and uh you can miss it it's easy to not
notic do it again all right so if I'm
I'm here in fact like let's
say let's say you know I was I like got
all
like wrapped up to
here then I could just sort
of and then it becomes a pattern that's
repeatable and slow back and forth and
drillable yeah like
this go on your right side yeah yeah
there it
is on the left
so so when when you look over here and
that's like your forward side that's
where you're going to drag up then when
you come over here and then you want to
look at your arm that's on top it's like
doing it from reverse where you can drag
down right so I can be like popping that
up or I can drop it down on the other
side up through the hole down through
the hole up through the hole down
through the
hole the bunny jumps the bunny hides the
bunny jumps The Bunny The more you
extend your arms out here you have a an
elongated frame to fit them in right
right but exactly but once you make a
quarter turn to wall plane you do want
to kick your elbows out because you want
to have this you want to have it
elongated that way with the plane so now
we're about to start doing some similar
feeling things swinging this through
there but now you really are going to be
kicking your elbows
out right so it's stretched out to make
it long this way flatten the flatten it
to your chest and kick your elbows out
to to get it around here so you end up
doing this sort of
like so it's going to be real real close
to both sides of the turning in on it
right about in these spinning props um
and really like I can Orient my spin
planes like this framewor work here so
maybe there's an audience there and
that's what I want to show them and I
should be able to like move around you
know
fre in
here
um I think it's important to sort of
think of these as the boundary planes
the bounding box I get like honestly a
lot of this stuff got elucidated for me
from 3D modeling because there's
conventions there that mathematicians
and physicists have had to figure out to
really describe what very mostly and
accurately what's going on in 3D space
um and so essentially like I'm this odd
shaped complex body instead of just like
a little block or something but sort of
the the bounds of where I may be in
space can be confined by a bounding Box
made of simple planes and for po it's
even really sort of simpler like even
though we sort of talk about like planes
in a cube and all that you can use that
that visual like really really the
simplest is just a bounding hallway two
parallel planes that I'm in between my
my poy as they're moving around will
come to this boundary leave it come to
this boundary leave
it then we fractalize
it so not only are these big macro two
walls framing my body inside of it but
there's also spaces that are created on
either side of my arm where it's like
now now I
have
Sor the fans they do the same thing like
now we have this sort of microcosm
macrocosm thing going
on exactly hold it hold it like this
like this yeah so so here's the big
macro body frame but then there's also
this like mic microcosm here with this
other toy that gets framed by my AR arms
and then there's sort of an intermediate
one where they connect here in between
my
arms I need
figure and just when you break it down
geometrically to what's going on and how
your body has to move literally any
pretty much any move that we do like
simple move naturally between the Big
Frame that we're used to like all around
our body you can shrink that down with
this and this and make a little micro
version of it in different places here
so a lot of times that almost instinct
to lean over is kind of like you're
leaning over the the stopping point the
stopping boundary yeah yeah um
interesting so like over time this sort
of started to consciously develop as as
an awareness and a body
awareness of like how by moving my body
into different positions I'll end up
yeah like fr
framing these situations
um I would just keep this in the back of
your mind as you play with this stuff
and look for do thises all the time
with spinning in between the legs yeah
right yeah
exactly well or or one way to think
about that is well okay there's two
different ways that there's two
different there's this yinong of
negative space of frames going on
there's the imaginary COI planes that
are really these little like boundary
conditions that are in between body
parts where you can put the COI cuz if
my body part is here POI can't be there
but it can be here or here right yeah so
there's like Yin frames those are your
po po planes and yangong is you it is
physically you like where you frame
around your poy where you end up moving
your body around that in thing that
where the poy can go so you're always
like your body and the PO are always
finding these ways to to interlock so
the the imaginary boundaries are Dynamic
are static rather and then the body is
the dynamic oh my God this is going to
be hard boundary yeah in a way it's it's
sort of like you can if you're already
sort of used to thinking about a
performance plane and that being sort of
static because it's always facing the
audience no matter how you're turning
yeah that's the first level of the
fractal right that's the first level of
complexity but you can start hanging on
that that idea of well I'm putting a
performance plane here there's a there's
a whole construct there's like this
plane and that plane and that inner
plane and that plane and like and like
then and there's also like for the the
small inner planes there's one below the
arms and one above the arms too okay
right so it's like have that so yeah
under my arms right so see how I can get
into this space in right in front of my
face or can get into this in front of my
tummy so that like that's on either side
but technically now where the fan is is
going to be your hand and your arm kind
of blocking everything even when I turn
sideways I still sort of have those
spacings here they're just like half
accessible and I get here where they're
full accessible I can even turn around
like if I'm a real pretzel I can like do
these inside planes and things behind my
back behind the head is sort of the
limit just because of the way your elbow
bends funny and you can sort of kind of
fake it but it's really hard to cleanly
do that behind your head but it's all
it's all there this framework sort of is
insinuated like you said it's almost
like it's static and the only time it
changes is if like you're changing your
plane orientation to someone else ah and
then you're dynamically moving your body
framing to to straddle these planes
appropriately so that the boy goes
through and doesn't yeah cuz that's that
that's never a fun thing that's never F
where the is
keep it real John keep it real uh
spinning let's spin like inward down the
center line so start out with that hand
underneath and it's going to be the same
idea like you're dragging that hand up
and through bottom hand like it's it's
literally like dragging this up and over
but now it's oriented
sideways and this is like it's really
useful to be able to drag like if I try
to if I just try to swing static if my
Foy aren't really short like I'm hitting
myself there right so really like drag
the head around get that isolated
feeling and notice how as as I wrap
around this arm I do actually
shift I shift a little bit that way and
then come back to here right so I'm like
stretching out with where the Foy is
momentarily to optimize this this space
and then back to Center oh
okay stretch stretch
stretch yeah so like if I if I really
shorten this stuff up like yeah okay so
I can with short short short poy I can
just stand here and do it but
realistically see I'm moving the
butterfly side to side which like if I
exaggerate that actually makes this
really
cool of like funky effect it's a nicer
looking that's how I'm actually able to
get around
there put it in front with a with the
loop with the
loop
so and there's actually like I said
unless it's super short there's going to
be a little back in for can you break
that down one more time that little one
by one step I like that that was
actually probably going to be really
useful so with thread the needle we
doing this sort of thing stacking not
only which hand is on top but which is
behind and which is in front that keep's
changing so what you're going to be
doing is whichever hand is coming back
underneath you're actually going to turn
that inward for an ins swing and drag it
through the arm to get it on
top oh okay so it's that draw the circle
on the tummy get over the arm and the
more you kind of get the feeling of
where it actually is on your body the
more you can stick your elbows out and
I'm doing the simple version with
together time it's just a TW
beat but honestly I I pref
split time like this so you got to make
sure you know split time 3 beat thread
the needle which by the way an easy way
to break down like okay together time
you stack your hands vertically in line
with that sort of vertical mirror effect
where they're meeting split Time meets
side to side it's got a horizontal
mirror and you stack your hands on that
Horizon side next side by side next to
each other so a really easy way to learn
split time thread the needle is to
stack your hand across the other oh
stack your hand across the
other getting used to both of those
positions until and that's your
prerequisite for the inverted one so now
so now notice how much smoother this is
because this is three beats three
rotations you have a little extra time
in between each in swing you have to do
yeah and it just it just really feels
like it flows a lot smoother than this
like thing right sure
um but yeah this thing's great like from
here you naturally sort of get that
moving it back and forth thing sort of
play with moving that
around um and this is I love this
because naturally not only are you
moving back and forth but like one toy
is coming up through the center while
the other's dropping
down look familiar think you do split
time opposite
yeah so come under an this can turn
into inverted wall playe split time
butterfly opposite
flowers reverse anti- spin triple
toses still with the twist still my
favorite part of that with
twist you remember that right from the
spinner sa video yeah I call
antipin
see how like I I'm I'm making an arm
frame that's pointing One Direction and
you could it's like you got you got a
bicycle wheel basically your arms are
the are the uh the bike frame B frame
there you
go and you can turn that around right
okay but not not only can you turn that
around you can start playing with when
when you turn the bike frame you're
flipping your wrists you could also push
just push the wrists back and forth so
you can sort of really break down like
can I push this one out in front can I
put it back like when can I turn like I
can push that one and push it back I
could flip just one out and back in I
could flip the other one out and back in
I could like I can lifp one out then
push then flip in I can flip one in push
like it's own Dr there's all these
sequences that you can just start making
more and more complex of like when you
sort of push like in and out of that
frame and when which wrist flips that's
really quantizing of breaking down what
you're doing
fluidly with all this stuff and this is
the
seam right right here this position and
flipping that that's like the seam that
stitches reverse and forward together
intermediately and so from here like
most people see barrel rolls like going
on over here right but check this out
from here I have this barrel roll and
that barrel roll right and and this
barrel
roll or that Barrel big barrel roll
right
or and I know we didn't even really get
the barrel roll thing but like okay so
here's here's like more that not stuff
swing and
whatnot they all add together nicely the
I I really think like if you take your
time and get into the ins swinging stuff
first like you're not just going to
learn barrel rolls and say oh I know how
to do my Barrel rolling this is it this
what I can do rolling that around like
you're you're going to be ready to start
exploring all this funky stuff you can
do I still can't wait than so God I've
got about 6 months in material right
now for poy so I'm not going to do any
POI workshops at flame flame like maybe
it's lined up with the stage here and
getting comfortable sort of moving
around to the plane
boundary keeping it there and then when
you get to the plane boundary stepping
through that door flipping over your
wrist flips at that point continuing on
So eventually you should be able to just
like so I had to do sound effects and
you can do that like if you want to if
you want to start making that more
challenging you could be isolating that
the whole time getting used to moving
around in isolation you could be like
doing a cat eye the whole time moving
around a cat eye you can you can start
picking more complicated ways to keep
the boy like right there and move around
it now happening that
[Music]
was what's happening is
this right you've got this axis of
rotation you've got the Poise spinning
around it when I'm spinning out in front
of me like this my
arm my arm is lined up with the axis
right so it's a particular feeling that
my body has to have control of where my
wrist is sort of rolling around like on
a wheel
axle the more the more I oh no keep that
there keep that this stays put in in
Space the more I move I'm going from arm
perpendicular to the circle to closer
and closer my arm is parallel with the
circle and I'm having to do a different
feeling thing to my body's proprio
section to keep the same
stability and we sort of take for
granted that goes on but if you can get
used to that and all of the angles
between perpendicular and like getting
really tight close parallel to the PO in
all four directions all four directions
forward and backward exactly exact
that's the thing this this simple
concept so really like for poy this is a
traditional Club spinning P right here
notice how it's never going behind my
head
yeah six rotations you can actually line
this up in a hexagon like I'm thinking
about when I when I transition up here
that's the top point of the hexagon ioss
behind at that point back at that point
there's another the low point of the
hexagon
there six yeah yeah yeah exactly so
that's a nice way to really smooth it
out into an even round
Fountain um but like back in the day
people were like I do a fourward wheat
and a backward wheat and then one of
these guys like that's sort of like what
what mutated into a koi
fountain but I mean if you're G to do
this if you're G to add that there you
could
also
like add one down add that right or you
could do it with what we're sort of
playing with a little
bit Yeah and then missing the bottom
part which you can totally do but you
might as well be aware of like the
symmetries available to you in your
body what was um I noticed you went
under the armpit on that one right down
a little bit so that's what Nick calls a
4x4 Fountain like a good way to think
about it is actually I like teaching it
with body tracing so check this out
you're like you you're under the armpit
uhhuh you come down to here and you
rotate your wrist which means this arm
is now in the armpit then you come up to
here and you rotate your wrist behind
your head armpit wrists in front armpit
wrists behind
oh
okay right so like when I was doing it I
was really like doing it deep like more
armpits and
shoulders you can but you can do it like
really arms out like like more of a
flowery fountain that was
that and you can do it with arm
tracing real real extended
dramatic that looks very uh very smooth
and comfortable looking where you can
almost like around the big circle Over
the Rainbow down here all that
stuff really not only notice that you're
you're pointing your Cross Point targets
around around around around you in a
circle this way but really pay attention
to
um two sides so remember those boundary
planes I was talking about I have a
boundary plane here right now I would
think of it as in front of me but it'll
change if I change my body so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say like
ocean side you know building side right
so it's like ocean building ocean
building ocean building
o so that's really like right I
can I can reorient my body without
getting as confused by focusing on those
things and making sure I'm like keeping
the Rhythm as I'm pointing my cross
points and turning around right up here
is where it gets weird right cuz you're
you're doing it this way and when you're
up there your cross points pointing up
you're going building ocean and you turn
around underneath
that like
it's really disoriented until you like
focus on it almost looks like you easily
lose the plane on that
one so that's a really interesting uh
exercise this as well that I think even
most advanced Spinners have missed
um and so you can turn your body really
slowly at first
yeah
or you can like try to
like speed up and there at at a certain
speed that you're rotating you'll sink
up so that like like check this out it's
behind my head behind my
head behind my head right so
like so it gets to the point where
you're not even even doing this anymore
you're just like going back
[Music]
turn and you
canst around inside of
that and that can happen down here by
the hips which topologically is
important to think of as get below the
armpit below the arm cuz like
so
I'm getting a little a little ad jumpy
right now but let me just say this
um who who's familiar with like the an
anatomical divisions of
bodies not so much Electronics guy you
know like the the the coronal plane
slices a body into front and back okay
the sagittal plane slices us into left
and right and the transverse it's
usually at the center of mass like VI to
top and bottom but for poy spinning for
prop
manipulation purposes it's at the
shoulder so there's an above the
shoulders reflection and a below the
shoulders
reflection keeping those reflective
planes that chop your body up in mind
you can get really creative with like
how you take a basic move and put it in
different places around your body and
sort of like do it mirror images places
that that alone the more I became
conscious of that like just like look I
can take this basic move I can put it
over there I can put it there I can put
it
here when you start thinking about it
that way it's not like you're learning
more different thingses or have many
different moves it's like really part of
this like form to understand how you
move around your body so the reason I
bring that up
though at
[Music]
the the uh transverse chopping you above
and below
shoulders just keep in the back of your
mind that if if you're doing an exercise
below your shoulders like this there's
also one that goes
on
above which is where I got got to that
funky flower foldy over this sort of
thing and that looks almost like you're
isolating it for a second like it looks
almost like you're dragging your hand
with it right or you're dragging the
leash right right
um hey get
over and also the um quick question on
the folding and like down uh I noticed
the way like your positioning is I don't
really want to move the the camera but
the positioning is it kind of looks
almost like um a half of a meltdown yeah
exactly is that um is that a good drill
to get into that all CU I don't know how
to do this exactly and that's actually
that's a really good point when you when
you get behind your head or behind your
back especially uh like as soon so as
long as your shoulder muscles are
controlling your arm to the front side
of the cornal plane you've got a lot of
strength and uh precision
and neurological like awareness and
control of what's going on as soon as
you start getting back behind there your
strength is like at 30% like you lose a
bunch of control strength and awareness
um so instead of trying to like muscle
back
here it's much nicer like as you get
twisted up into these sort of positions
to like I literally temporarily I rest
my arm on the small of my back and sort
of use body to get the next position
yeah cuz your Bott body's a lot stronger
yeah you're joint lock here like
you really want to try to spin like that
people don't want to be in that position
as it
is yeah so all this
stuff see how I keep like getting
whichever arm is the most across my body
like yeah it definitely looks like
you're you're putting it against your
back that the inside
arm
yeah um and yeah this whole twisting
exercise feel the up and down swing once
again like once you get behind you
focusing on feeling like how your wrist
is scoping it down and scooping it
straight up your back rather than like
tipping over on you right like they
didn't know how that feels so you can't
see it you can feel it mhm is really
good and you'll continue to twist up
until you can get on the small of your
back sort of find what's comfortable
right there on the small of your back
and if you want to be a real pretzel
like you can start
like to gother that's of
just ridiculous painful
yeah
to it's almost like what would go like
past the
um uh oh yeah yeah so the whole like
split time is a sequential right you got
to really get used to I remember I
totally remember this too where like
whenever I was in Split time and I get
into like sort of unfamiliar teror story
like it was really easy to get back into
together yeah with split time really
think about this like get emphasize a
sequential feeling like this goes then
you turn then this goes okay right so
it's like sweep turn sweep okay and as
far as the weaves are concerned is that
the same similar process with the weave
or cuz you said you had the extension
weave where you have the scoop on it but
wait oh maybe I didn't understand your
question were you talking about going
from Le and tuing it here yeah oh cuz
the way you described it when you were
turning with it you said you scoop right
but um almost every time I ever do a
scoop and that includes with a split
time so that still was helpful it winds
up going same time instead of weaving so
you're you're you're talking about doing
like this yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I know there that
same playing with the sequential thing
is uh is where it's at like whenever
you're turning with these tuck turns you
what this the arm you're turning away
from tucks first as you turn you're take
you're carrying this along with you and
then tucking it as you're completing the
turn okay and that that will really
separate yeah really watch that so it's
like tuck carry tuck and as this one is
tucking then this one
is as this tucks that comes out another
uh and actually a way to look at that is
that you're actually using two different
cross points a weave they're both
hitting the same basic Cross Point
sequentially hit hit cross cross cross
cross cross cross right with this I'm
going I tuck and then as I do that I hit
a Cross Point here on this side of me
and as I come in here I'm getting a
Cross Point there on that side of me
okay when that happens in Split time so
think about this so think about there's
a cross point on either side of me that
here like there're my cross points
right if I'm in together time I can
cross both through her and do some stuff
then both through her if I'm in Split
time one is crossing there and one is
crossing there at the same time okay
which that like for most people split
time feels like that sort of cross cross
like through one Cross Point so there's
this different thing that happens in
Split
time see I'm I'm in split split Time
same
direction but my cross points are
landing there there to the Cross points
land at the same time because it's two
different cross points oh okay um so
when I'm when you're doing
this I really really to break this down
it's like I get to this position like
when we were twisting up and then when
that happens it's really that like
both both of them do their figure eight
at the same time they both cross at the
same and then that keeps it split time
just now of course reverse but yeah so
the cross points happen at the same time
but how you tuck in and out of it
happens sequentially so it's like
sequential they both cross but this
thing's movement is sequential to make
that happen it's it's a bit of a paradox
when you break it down that far yeah um
so don't think too hard about it but if
you're playing with it maybe you'll
you'll notice like a oh wait a second
like I'm like sort of trying to like I'm
actually trying to tuck that one first
the normal we have the normal inversion
one in spin version of this thing we're
coming up and out
yeah
and then the Annie spin it you go spin
version like if you were coming up and
out you'll just reverse that you'd be
coming down and out to go up
ah and this could be translated into a
forward butterfly too right or right
yeah so then going the other way around
you could come down come down the center
up the outsides and it'll be ins inside
or you can um up and out which I think
is we're originally doing that's the
inside an spin okay this is this one is
the anti spin with them going inwards
yeah okay so forward forward more
because of the fact that it swings in
most of the moves that you're doing it's
going to point in on it whereas
um if you're going with ever the
direction it's pointing on it I want to
it's kind of hard to explain that
describe notice how that pedal points
out away from me yeah out away out away
out away up away out away down away up
okay yeah yeah and in spin is like in
towards me up and in up there and in
down there and in
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
w
[Music]
it's so
pretty oh
yeah
[Applause]
I get it get it get
[Music]
[Applause]
it
he me
[Music]
like
nice
oh my
[Music]
[Applause]
God
anybody oh anybody left wo yeah
going